[Musica]
oggi il nuovissimo episodio degli
scherzi alla maestra volta ne faremo
degli scherzi a tema natalizio infatti
tipo le faremo esplodere l'albero di
natale tante altre cose super divertente
pre lasciate un bel mi piace
stiamo per finire il gioco ci sono
pochissimi scherzi mi dispiace troppo
perché è diventato il nostro gioco
preferito il super divertente di
consigliateci zone i commenti che giochi
fare dopo che avremo finito scheri tizia
questo dovrebbe essere il penultimo
episodio poi andate a vedere anche gli
scherzi che ha fatto vitale nel suo
canale ora mettetevi comodi prendete i
pop corn e iniziamo subito con il primo
che lo scherzo
credo che scrivi teacher abbia bisogno
di un po di aiuto per decorare il suo
albero di natale
sicuramente citiamo uno stadio già
bayonne stile
[Musica]
quali
molto bene allora spiriti solo ha detto
francis che il suo fidanzato sarà
rimarrà molto colpito da come ho fatto
bene l'albero di natale poi ha fatto 3 2
1 e si sono accese le luci dell'albero
di natale quindi noi dobbiamo aiutarla a
decorarla dove metteremo qualcosa di
esplosivo nell'albero scritto sotto
nella missione che dobbiamo fare per di
trovare qualcosa per sostituire le
decorazioni natalizie e quindi
sicuramente non doverle sostituire a
proprio delle bombe
ora vediamo che cosa troviamo questo c'è
la neve caduti signori teaser che bello
se non avete visto l'igloo è rinato se
non avete visto gli episodi presidenti
abbiamo già fatto uno scherzo invernale
ascritti 0 e cioè mentre pattinava fissi
noi ghiacciate stato super divertente
mirato valdostano avete visto gli altri
episodi andate a vederli poi dopo questo
video ma ora troviamo subito le bombe
che vita ne sta controllando giù nello
scantinato se fosse però in cucina
quindi potrebbe essere molto vicina c'è
qualcosa qui una scatola cosa c'è dentro
piccole provato dice sostituisci le
palline di natale con queste bombe
elettrica
allora vediamo ha decorato la casa per
mangiare con l'albero mastica che bella
guardate sociali sterline le palline sta
cercando qualcos'altro magari riusciamo
ad aggiungere qualcos'altro anche
all'albero è perché altra decorative
dovevi fare un bagno sopra toniolo è
molto vicino noi controlliamo sempre le
camere di sicurezza e nel bagno di su ok
sta cambiando stanco che non aveva mai
giocando nel bagno che con il tempo è
uscita dal bagno non so in che stanza
stia andando e cosa state cercando
secondo voi vitale che cosa abbiamo qui
sono questi rai rosso e spray giando
degli spray per dipingere le bombe così
non vede che non sono le palline di
natale bravo altrimenti avrebbe scoperto
avremmo fallito la scherza come ti è
successo molte volte ce n'è accorta
arrivando arrivando ai seggi dalle
strade
forse non ci ho visto ancora che i ora
bisogna andare all'albero di natale
sostituire le cose prima che se ne
accorga
un aspetto ho paura di prendermi la
scossa bravo è tutto perché un sacco di
volte c'è il successo che abbiamo preso
la sposta infatti dice fai in modo che
sembrino delle palline di natale ora
l'unico di scampare ma non deve
ricollegare la corrente
no non ce l'ha fatta o forse no perché
sono poi esplodono vero o no che
chiamiamo si capivano lei è ancora al
piano di sopra nel disonore essendo e
vedrà cosa sezione all'alba ecco ecco
[Musica]
[Applauso]
web
bruciacchiato tutti e due non sono
spiriti ferma anche freddy troppo
divertente questo scherzo stiamo ora una
cosa che scheri tingere ama più di
qualsiasi altra cosa nel mondo è il suo
blog che dovrebbe essere ovunque è un
tipo di frullato quindi dice prendiamolo
ancora più speciale va affatto un
miglior attore è andato anche farmi
ossario a berlino davanti sdraiato che
ha fatto piedi le recchie megaro tutorio
con la goletta verde
allora si è scritto di provare qualcosa
per rovinarle il drink il frullato che
sara lin
come possiamo trovare qualcosa
straordinario tutto in cucina beh si
svegliano ingrediente schifoso lei sta
guardando la tv come sempre molto
divertita
ok siamo una nuova dice che dobbiamo
mettere quando si è molto vicino a
tirare oppure non devo una torta
ok ok si sta dirigendo verso la porta
d'uscita
prendiamo la torta per sicurezza così si
arriva che la tiriamo a doni che ci sono
le uova se questo bacinella d'acqua è
morto ma dobbiamo sbrigare o non è
capitato questa basta aiuto a fare
quando qui allora prova a mettere delle
uova nel frullatore secondo me le perle
qui
[Applauso]
cambiare la cannella
forse bisogna pensare a questo perché a
scappare il campo troppo gattone sta
scendendo tra l'altro sia meglio
midnight a me è ok siamo nuovamente in
cucina ora proveremo a mettere le uova
nella forse quello che abbiamo sbagliato
perché dovevamo mettere luogo andato a
male altrimenti brucio è salito in
superficie le imprese che si si lo vedi
qui sotto che è quello vero guardate
l'immagine diverta bene allora vista
scendere ma dove ce la facciamo
e allora vediamo bene dove sta scendendo
qui
ora dobbiamo mettere la cannella e vedi
lo dice qua sotto aggiunge qualcosa per
me arrivano dall orrore del marcio o che
io non potevo scappare
ok stanno detto gira la caviglia
[Musica]
bush ha fatto male allo stomaco prossimo
scherzo scritti c'era molta fretta di
divertirsi quest'inverno però un gioco
di parole in inglese
in pratica i ching che vuol dire avere
il pluri 38 si dice i ching per dire
avere molta fretta non vedere l'ora come
noi però significa letteralmente aver il
prurito
sicuramente le fare uno scherzo in cui
avrò fronte c'è solo un martello e la
solita trappola razzista niente
consiglio questa volta
[Musica]
in tal malan ha detto che prendo questo
questo è che scherzo che povero questa
volta centra il prurito con il fatto che
dobbiamo farla tipo raffreddare a in
modo che abbia prurito mentre indossa la
giacca per prendere qualcosa che le
famiglie il prurito farle mettere la
giacca quindi fare in modo che avrà
freddo per sempre in una finestra
abbastanza segreto al piano di sopra ha
25mila armate si era fatto divertire
trovare l'udc anche se si veste sempre
uguale sta salendo
ok ok e in una camera da letto con le
scatole
vediamo queste c'è qualcosa giusto in
tempo ci stava per vedere non trovare
questa cosa per farle da mettere nella
giacca ma non sappiamo dove può essere
lei sta facendo il giro di sopra o poco
paura che anche il ct del rumore di già
avete scritto che quando li si ferma
all'improvviso e guarda tipo così
immobile vuol dire che ci ha sentito e
quindi che sembra già fibre poi però se
non troviamo la crostata mettere già
avete anche voi vi siete spaventati
spuntate dall'improvvisa scrivi ti
dobbiamo trovare ancora quel qualcosa da
mettere andata dove allora insect powder
devo dire polvere prince e borotalco in
pausa
ok quindi era vuol dire a polvere
prurito insomma la polvere che fa venire
il prurito allora non ci resta che
metterle la nella giacca e contro a
bravo chi è ritrovato la giacca sì
perché l'abbiamo messa adesso è arrivato
pare per un detto che vuole voler
mettersi la giacca comunque c'è scritto
assicurati che lei fa una scala di
sicurezza che lei soffre quando farà il
bagno
dobbiamo mettere qualcosa nel bagno ecco
la sto mettendo lo giacca ora dobbiamo
fare qualcosa al bagno e bagno e qui non
lo so di non più amo il lavandino che ti
facciamo vediamo l'indizio pesiamo
allora è l'indizio dice di bloccare
fornitura di acqua calda come facciamo
bloccarla
dobbiamo trovare la caldaia guardateli
si sta gratta che è molto infastidita
dalla polvere sanno fare meglio ma noi
non abbiamo fatto in tempo a cambiare la
candidata eccola la galleria in bagno
che succederà
[Musica]
ma no allora che cosa è successo
praticamente noi abbiamo fatto uno
scherzo che in cui abbiamo messo la
polvere nella giacca lei aveva prurito
quindi quello era riuscito però lei è
andata subito a fare il bagno ha subito
per togliersi la polvere il prurito noi
però dovevamo prima che lei andasse a
fare il bagno andare e modificare la
caldaia cioè bloccare l'acqua calda
e così lei e non farsi il bagno ma era
fredda ma qua però non siamo riusciti a
fare in tempo quindi ora proviamo
un'altra strategia e cioè proviamo prima
a bloccare l'acqua calda così avrà solo
l'acqua fredda poi ammettere la polvere
che da prurito nella giacca vs un tubo
forse questa forse dateci una mano un po
ragazzo quando andrà poi a fare il bagno
andrà direttamente ad avere in acqua
fredda mi dico se ci riusciamo a perché
come facciamo ad arrivare la soprastante
speriamo che sia questa la soluzione
si ok
chiuso questo speriamo che funzioni così
non se ne accorge ora dobbiamo fare il
resto cioè si andare a prendere la
polvere metterla nella giacca però
dobbiamo sbrigarci prima che lei vada a
fare il bagno perché potrebbe fare il
bagno anche prima ne potrebbe mettersi
già la giacca senza la polvere quindi è
uno di quegli scarti un po complessi in
cui bisogna fare tante cose
lei è uscita fuori una lex proprio la
scala spero che non si era forse vi
abbiamo spostato la manovella perché è
strano che sia uscita fuori a contro
ordinaria ma infatti sta già ritornando
club rossonero perché siamo qua a
sentire i rumori adesso non mi ricorda
dov'era la polvere
era nella stanza del pestaggio
allora io ti avviso lei e in cucina
perché avremo ancora un piano però
sicuramente arriverà acqua perché stiamo
offrendo 10.000 porte dovrebbe essere
qui sì sì ecco la bravo presa
lei sta salendo però per sé stante
sapere anche cosa succede quando metti
le altre polveri nelle nella giacca
d'ora la giacca e nella sua camera che
qui
ok li sta guardando la tv abbiamo ancora
un po di tempo è bravo mettiamo in
questa rosa
si ok arrivi se fosse al pare e non c'è
più scritto di togliere l'acqua calda
quindi forse siamo riusciti a fare tutto
questo
vediamo la scopriremo strada quella
reazione
[Musica]
si sta trattando ancora le dà proprio
fastidio
si si sta andando verso il bagno adesso
ecco vediamo secolo riusciti
[Musica]
sembra che fa preda l'acqua è fredda
certo il termometro è stato super
divertente questo scherzo vederla
rapprentazione cammino belli stabilito
che cattivissima quale fate il vostro
scherzo preferito il mio stato
l'albero di natale era super mini è vero
però in effetti anche quando correvo al
bagno con la mano chi preferisco
quest'ultimo verso il cui primo quello
dell'albero di natale in voi mi
raccomando la sorte un bel mi piace e
ora andate a vedere gli altri bisogni
scheri teacher o scegliete voi la
casellina che vi lasciamo qua su cui
cliccare cliccate su quella che
preferite